the ethiopian government is calling this
a law and order operation but it's clear
the conflict here is
far more than that with widespread
evidence of war crimes
sky news has documented numerous human
rights abuses in the tigray
how concerning is the deteriorating
situation there and what more can be
done diplomatically
to end the violence we're extremely
concerned
uh about the situation antigua whether
it's on the humanitarian
or whether it's on on the human rights
and that is why
we have consistently called for greater
access
for both the united states says it is
already clear what is happening
on the ground it's accusing forces
aligned with the government of
systematically forcing people
from their homes they need to come out
and
uh a force that will not uh abuse the
human rights of
the people of tigre or commit acts of
ethnic cleansing which we've seen
the emergency in ethiopia is now a top
priority for the u.s
senator chris coons is arriving in the
country as an
envoy and humanitarian aid has been
ramped up dramatically
here at the state department there is
growing concern
about the situation in ethiopia the fear
is if the violence worsens it could
destabilize the entire region
it's why officials are now working with
their european counterparts to try and
forge
a diplomatic consensus but it's more
than that because it signals that it's
no longer
america first under a biden
administration
the us is back as a global leader
and experts say without a broad
diplomatic agreement
the crisis will be impossible to resolve
i don't think one country even the
united states is going to be able
to do what needs to be done this needs
to be a whole of
africa initiative as well as a whole of
a human rights
mechanisms initiative because the the
tensions there are
so deep seated and and right now they're
literally at a boiling point the danger
of course is that with trust broken on
all sides
a diplomatic breakthrough will take time
to broker
and that is time people living amidst
this violent chaos
do not have alex rossi sky news
washington